rudy giuliani and jenna ellis throw
sydney powell under the bus
team trump's legal options narrow and
the media insists they are credible
after completely destroying their own
credibility i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn stand up for
your digital rights take action at
expressvpn.com
slash event we're going to jump right
into the news but first let me remind
you that the news itself is crazy that
means a lot of volatility it means
you're not sure where the stock market
is going to go you don't know whether
your politicians are going to inflate
the currency
are they going to blow out the spending
what they're going to do with regard to
trade monetary policy this is why you
should be at least a little bit
diversified into precious metals the
people i've been working with for years
are my friends over at birch gold gold
is a safe haven against inflation and
bad decisions by politicians
which means like if it's a hedge against
reality because that stuff is happening
all the time
where do you buy your gold birch gold
group that's who i trust this month
they're going to give you an extra bonus
for black friday through november 27th
for every 5 000 purchase birch gold will
send you a free silver american eagle
there's no limit on the amount of free
silver you can receive which is a great
way to teach your kids the importance of
diversification
to qualify when you text ben to 47 47 47
just tell the birch gold representative
about this offer even if you're
investing in a precious metals ira
you'll still get the physical silver
delivered directly to your door which is
awesome text ben 247-4747
get that free information kit on
diversifying into gold and then call my
friends over at birch gold they have an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau
countless five star reviews tech spends
47 47 47
open that precious metals ira get your
free silver before november 27th
over the weekend the the donald trump
legal options
seemed to narrow fairly dramatically
they had a lawsuit
that was in pennsylvania and it was
struck down with prejudice i mean it was
it was basically basically said we're
not going to allow you to refile the
lawsuit nor are we going to allow you to
amend
the lawsuit the federal judge his name
is matthew brown who's appointed by
obama but he was appointed
at the behest of senator pat toomey he's
a republican he is also
a federalist society member so this is
not a wild left-wing judge
just because he was appointed by obama
very often low-level district judges
are appointed at the behest of senators
from various states
through sort of bipartisan agreements in
any case
the associated press reported a federal
judge issued a scathing order on
saturday dismissing the trump campaign's
feudal attempts to block the
certification of votes in pennsylvania
shooting down claims of widespread
irregularities with mail-in ballots
the case was always a long shot to stop
president elect joe biden's inauguration
that of course is the language of the ap
but it was president donald trump's best
hope to affect the election results
through the courts mostly because of the
number of electoral votes 20 at stake
in pennsylvania u.s district court judge
matthew brown wrote in his order that
trump had asked the court to
disenfranchise almost 7 million voters
this is one of the problems that the
remedy
did not seem like it was calibrated to
the sin if you can identify two people
who had their votes
counted wrongly or who should have had
their votes counted and instead were
disenfranchised
that really is general the court's not
going to order that entire state of 7
million people all of those voters
then be disenfranchised and instead
electors be appointed by the state
legislature
bran said one might expect that when
seeking such a startling outcome a
plaintiff would come formidably armed
with compelling legal arguments and
factual proof of rampant corruption
that has not happened trump would have
still needed to win
in arizona and georgia and other states
in order to actually win the election
trump has been reaching out to michigan
legislatures legislators in
in the white house on friday he was uh
working with these lawmakers he's
suggesting apparently
this is the speculation anyway he was
suggesting that they select their own
electors
right now the situation in michigan
remains a little bit up in the air
the state board of canvassing could
theoretically split 2-2 in which case
there'd be a bunch of lawsuits filed
and then we'd find out how things end in
michigan but in pennsylvania
the situation is just about wrapping up
and again the the baseline problem with
the situation in pennsylvania is that
the lawsuit
was just slimly predicated they had
allegations
of equal protection violations there
were legal problems with that because
again
it was a lawsuit that was filed
basically on the basis
of the state taking certain procedural
certain procedural rules under
consideration
the equal protection claim is a federal
claim to make a federal claim you have
to show that a federal right was
violated
a federal equal protection claim based
on two different counties having two
different standards of votes being
counted and voter fraud not being the
issue
was probably not going to end with the
disenfranchisement of seven million
people in pennsylvania as andy mccarthy
writes over at national review
judge brand's opinion sets forth a
variety of reasons for dismissing the
case
most of them are directed toward the
complaints of two individual plaintiffs
voters who claim that their ballots had
been improperly discounted the court
found the trump campaign had no standing
to sue
having posited no evidence that trump
was harmed in any cognizable way by the
manner in which the election was
conducted in pennsylvania see here's the
problem it was not the voters
suing it was the trump campaign suing
suggesting that things were unfair on
behalf of the trump campaign
in order for you to sue typically in a
lawsuit you have to have standing
right if my producer colton gets hit by
a car i can't sue the person driving
the car i mean nor what i mean i like
colton and all but but i can't sue the
person
driving the car because i don't have
standing to sue right i'm not the person
who's damaged colton would have to sue
in this situation if there was voter
fraud that occurred the voters
theoretically would have to sue unless
you could show systematic
voter fraud on behalf of the biden
campaign
the biggest problem again in that
lawsuit was as danny mccarthy has said
many times
the mismatch between the proposed remedy
and the prep
and the suggested harm the judge said
even if you accepted the premise that
the two voters in question were denied
the right to vote while others were not
the relief would be for them to have
their votes properly counted right you
just figure out how they were going to
vote and then you count their votes
it wouldn't be to disenfranchise seven
million people
in filing their original complaint on
november 9th the trump campaign claimed
extensive voter fraud
then apparently they uh they pulled
their voter fraud claims then they tried
very late
to reinstate their voter fraud claims
that happened on thursday night
but they did so in order to go back to
district court so they were saying okay
well now that they have basically
rejected our claims at this particular
court level we're going to go to the
supreme court but the problem is the
relief that they requested
from the appeals court was to go back to
district court so
you end up with a sort of weird position
where they want to get to the supreme
court eventually
and have the supreme court adjudicate
the voter fraud voter irregularity
claims and seek to
throw out the election in pennsylvania
essentially but they were claiming they
were going to go to the supreme court
directly the problem is that the grounds
upon which they appealed is that they
were not given leave to amend their
complaints
that now gets remanded back to the
district courts they should go back down
to a lower level court in order to make
this argument
the trump legal team was trying to kind
of turn a
salsier into a silk purse here by
suggesting that this was actually a
victory
rudy giuliani and jenna ellis issued a
response to the ruling they said today's
decision turns out to help us in our
strategy
strategy to get expeditiously to the u.s
supreme court although we fully disagree
with the opinion
we're thankful to the obama appointed
judge for making this this anticipated
decision quickly
rather than simply trying to run out the
clock we'll be seeking an expedited
appeal to the third circuit
there's a lot of evidence that in
pennsylvania democrats eliminated our
opportunity to present 50 witnesses and
other evidence
that election officials blatantly
ignored pennsylvania's law denying
independent review
okay but they're not actually again
appealing the decision to the third
circuit court of appeals
on the basis that they ignored the
evidence and therefore it needs to be
sent to the supreme court
they're saying they want leave to to
revise their complaints i know there's a
little bit of legalese it just means
that the timeline is longer
than it otherwise would be this doesn't
allow them to elevate up to the supreme
court
it causes them to elevate only to go
back down to the lower court which means
that you end up in this sort of endless
cycle of appeals judge bran
suggested of course that the the lawsuit
was bound to fail which of course
i mean in all likelihood it probably is
so that is the story in pennsylvania
meanwhile
in wisconsin the trump campaign is
attempting similar lawsuits we'll get to
that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that with all of the unrest out
there
gun sales been going through the roof
and there's a reason for that right you
want to protect yourself you want to
protect your family the big problem is
that even in
god forbid a situation in which you have
to protect yourself and your family
you very well could end up being dragged
into court you could end up being
prosecuted simply for defending yourself
or your family that's why you have to
know how to use your gun
and when to use your gun you need the
proper education and industry-leading
training to ensure your skills are sharp
when faced with danger plus
the uscca has purchased an insurance
policy that provides the association and
its members with self-defense liability
insurance
you need the uscca if you are a
responsible gun owner get started today
by texting gun
to 87 222 you'll receive the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting seven firearms
drills that could save your life and
much much more it's a 164-page guide
loaded with valuable information
in addition if you text today you'll be
entered to win a thousand dollars to put
toward a gun of your choice that you can
use to protect your family which is a
pretty
great deal everything is unpredictable
right now it's normal to want to protect
your family if you want to protect your
family in the best possible way
get involved with the uscca text gun to
87 222 right now again text gun to 87
222 for the 164 page
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide and you're entered to win
a thousand bucks to put toward a gun
of your choice go check them out right
now okay so
meanwhile in wisconsin according to the
washington post they are seeking to use
a recount
to attempt to invalidate votes in the
state making sweeping challenges to hold
categories of ballots
cast in the state's biggest two
democratic leaning counties
as a recount began on friday in dane and
milwaukee counties those are home to the
cities of madison and milwaukee trump's
lawyers argued officials should not
merely retabulate all the votes
cast instead they argued that a large
batch of ballots had been improperly
accepted and counted in the first place
in both dane and milwaukee they're
seeking to disqualify all absentee
ballots that have been cast before
election day
in person rather by mail
so that is likely to not succeed either
i mean they're making a legal challenge
suggesting that every absentee ballot
that was cast in person meaning that you
casted
an absentee ballot then you went and you
checked in person to make sure to double
check that your vote got counted
and you've cast a provisional ballot
that all of those should basically
be thrown out the unofficial tally still
shows biden up by about 20
000 votes in 2016 when jill stein the
green party candidate requested a more
extensive statewide recount it resulted
in trump widening his victory in
wisconsin by about 131 votes
the trump campaign's decision to target
for the recount the only two democratic
counties was obviously an attempt to
close the gap jenna ellis said every
american deserves to know that our
elections are conducted in a legal
matter no matter who they are or where
they live
our only goal is to ensure safe secure
and fair elections
there are a lot of accusations that
observers and media were being kind of
distanced from the actual
counting of the ballots unclear as to
whether that is a legal problem or not
in all likelihood the re at least the
baseline rationale that people are using
is they're saying you're not supposed to
be up
on the ballot so you can actually see
who voted for what because there is in
fact
a secret ballot trump campaign lawyer
stuart cars almost immediately accused
the newly sworn in milwaukee election
workers of starting to open and look at
ballot applications
before the board of canvassers
authorized it
and uh and rick bass who was a one of
the one of the election
monitors uh got very angry because a lot
of the uh
he's a republican he got angry because
some of the trump supporters were
apparently being
kind of loud during the election
observation
it's uh it's a big margin it's unlikely
that a recount is going to overcome it
which is of course why they are filing
legal challenges uh suggesting that the
absentee ballots have been improperly
counted in the first place so a recount
isn't going to do much this is sort of
the same strategy they adopted in
georgia
when the the trump legal team suggested
that a recount isn't going to change any
of the results because the big problem
is that people did not properly
signature match the first time around
that if you sent in a mail-in ballot
that people did not properly signature
match before they removed the signature
portion of the ballot and therefore a
bunch of illegal votes had already been
counted and if you recount illegal votes
you're just recounting illegal votes
the issue there is that you do have
republican and democratic observers in
georgia
who are actually matching the signatures
together so
that is where things stand with regard
to wisconsin meanwhile over in michigan
as i mentioned earlier team trump is
trying to
create a pathway whereby the michigan
legislature would declare a slate of
electors for trump
even though trump right now in the count
is down about 150 000 votes
in michigan the claim being that
widespread voter fraud and voter
irregularity make it impossible
for the count to be trusted this of
course has already
been quasi-adjudicated by a board of
canvassers in wayne county where it
split two two republicans and democrats
and then the republicans voted with the
democrats to certify
and then they tried to uncertify now the
thing is that the state board of
canvassers we will see how they vote
there are two republicans and two
democrats if they were to split
two to two then presumably there would
be a lawsuit trying to compel the state
board of canvassers to vote in favor of
certifying the election
at which point you would imagine that
the governor who happens to be a
democrat whitmer that she would vote to
certify
the election but you could theoretically
have a constitutional crisis this is
what the michigan house speaker
was talking about lee chatfield
republican
if there were to be a 2-2 split on the
state board of canvassers it would then
go to the michigan supreme court
to determine what their response would
be what their order would be
if they didn't have an order that it be
certified well now we have a
constitutional crisis in the state of
michigan
that's never occurred before because as
the federal constitution says
this is left up to the state
legislatures the state legislature
decided
long ago uh to do it this way so if this
way doesn't work obviously now we have
questions that have you know risen in
michigan okay so
that is uh that is the possible you know
constitutional crisis happening in
michigan in all likelihood this is
probably not going to
move forward in this way again the
lawsuit has basically been declared dead
in pennsylvania bearing some sort of
extraordinary circumstance uh the
recount in wisconsin is not likely to
result in any severe change the lawsuits
there
will be adjudicated if there's a lawsuit
in georgia it will be adjudicated
although there was a lawsuit that was
filed last week by a member of
team trump and uh that lawsuit was
plagued by a bunch of errors
in which for example the person who
filed the lawsuit included affidavits
that conflated michigan and minnesota
which was a real problem declaring that
the voter rolls in in michigan
had been overwhelmed by people who are
not registered to vote it turns out that
he was matching up stats from minnesota
two stats from michigan and then
comparing the voter account which of
course
uh is is doing the math wrong so all of
this uh is
is a problem for team trump i mean
there's no question that the legal path
for team trump has narrowed
just to be perfectly objective about
this which would mean that now would be
a time to bring forth as much evidence
as you could possibly muster
with regard to voter fraud and voter
irregularities sufficient to overcome
the presumption
that these votes are going to be
certified we know already that georgia's
going to certify we know that
pennsylvania is likely going to certify
once the votes are certified and the
electors are selected then it's just a
matter of the formalistic
vote of the electoral college on
december 14th
so time runs short now would be the time
to as sidney powell suggested
release the crack and there's only one
problem there which is that sydney pal
has now been ousted
from team trump we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about encrypting your data
let's talk about the data
that you have on your computer you don't
want anybody stealing that data
you don't want to be anybody tracking
what you do online i mean this is your
data
it's often easy for a hacker to buy
bypass wi-fi security
and steal your information by exploiting
flaws like crack that's crack with a k
in case you'd like to google it that's
why i use expressvpn to stay secure
online
it's hard to know whether your device or
network is vulnerable if you ever use
wi-fi at a hotel or shopping mall you're
sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption at all
the best way to ensure all of your data
is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers is to use expressvpn
just download the expressvpn app on your
computer or smartphone
tap one button to secure 100 of your
network data and then just use the
internet the way you normally would
expressvpn it's incredibly reliable it's
the fastest vpn service i've tried
they're also rated the world's number
one vpn provider by review sites like
techradar and cnet so
if you want the best in online security
and privacy protection head over to
expressvpn.com for three extra months
free with a one year package protect
your internet today
with the vpn i trust to keep my data
safe go to expressvpn.com to get started
again that's expressvpn.com ben
to get started okay so meanwhile you
remember that just last week
the trump legal team included three
lawyers it was rudy giuliani
who had been brought in very late in the
game to represent the trump team
in court in pennsylvania it didn't go
particularly well it was jenna ellis he
was a long-time trump campaign lawyer
and it was sydney powell sydney powell
was of course the lawyer for michael
flynn who did an excellent job with
michael flynn
and was considered fairly well respected
in the legal community
just last week jenna ellis had suggested
that this was the elite the elite strike
force team
for team trump here's what she had to
say at that press conference last week
remember this is such a short time frame
and this is an elite strike force team
that is working on behalf of the
president and the campaign
to make sure that our constitution is
protected we are a nation
of rules not a nation of rulers
okay so that was the take last week
that was the take last week was that
that sydney powell was an integral
member of the team he was standing up
there on the podium she was taking the
microphone
from rudy and of course the theory that
she laid out last week is that the
dominion voting systems had been hacked
and there are two separate theories laid
out by team trump
the theory that was put forward by rudy
giuliani had significantly
more legitimate bases at least
evidentiarily as far as we could see
that theory is that there had been voter
irregularities that observers have been
kept
from polling places they were told to
keep back and that provided the
possibility of voter fraud
there's one affidavit that he cited
suggesting that actual votes
had been brought by trashcan for joe
biden two places in detroit there wasn't
a lot of evidence to support that there
was one affidavit court in michigan
found that unconvincing but at least
there were affidavits at least there
were allegations
that were subject to the possibility of
verification
right he was alleging that there were
certain poll workers who were being told
by the democratic party to facilitate
with voter fraud
these were the sort of allegations he
was making now the problem for giuliani
is that he wasn't making a lot of those
allegations in court where he did make
them in court
they weren't sufficient evidentiarily
for a judge to sustain them
but again is there voter fraud is there
voter irregularity there certainly is in
every single election the only question
is to what extent
sydney powell is making a much much
deeper
accusation her accusation is that the
vote machines themselves have been
hacked
that basically dominion systems had at
one point had a relationship with a
company called sequoia sequoia had at
company called smart tech
smart tech had imbibed supposedly
material into their algorithms that
allowed for manipulation of the
algorithms
from the outside and therefore she had
suggested that some seven million votes
had been basically wiped from the rolls
for president trump
meaning that trump won 80 million votes
not 73 million bucks i mean these are
these are pretty broad
and uh and spectacular allegations
requiring a broad
base of evidence to be provided so i
said last week i'd like to see the
evidence to make up my mind in public
because the fact of the matter is that
she was making a claim to the media
i can't judge whether her claims are
true or false until i actually see the
evidence
so i'm not sure what i'm supposed to do
about that and then people are saying
well just wait for her to bring it
forward
in court i said okay that's fair in the
legal sense but she was making a claim
to the media
if she's asking for my opinion on what
she is saying i need to see evidence
of that what she is saying is true
before i'm likely to believe that seven
million vote i mean
what she was talking about is the
biggest voter scandal in the history of
the united states which means
the biggest voter scandal in the history
of democracy if you're literally talking
about the voting machines of the united
states being hacked to the point
where nearly 10 million votes are
shifted from one side to the other or
seven million votes
are simply lost in the mail if you're
making those sorts of claims you're
talking about the greatest act
of undermining of democracy in the
history of democracy
i mean it's an amazing amazing
accusation so you're going to require
some evidence of that and if you're not
going to bring it
in public view for people in the media
to judge or people in the public to
judge
and we're all just supposed to be asked
to take that on faith okay
then just say you bring it in court and
then bring it in court right because you
don't have a lot of time to prove that
also you would imagine that if the voter
fraud were that prevalent you should be
able to come up with evidence of it
okay so last week obviously this
resulted in tucker carlson
going to sydney palin saying can you
show us the evidence and we actually
asked andy pal to come on the program so
we could ask her about that
she never responded as far as i'm aware
tucker carlson did have
coordination with her team and she
basically blew tucker carlson off and
then suggested that he was a bad guy for
asking for evidence which is a
a proposition i find uh pretty pretty
ridiculous she also said she didn't have
time to do interviews
she then promptly appeared on newsmax
where she did interviews so she went on
newsmax
and she suggested that she was going to
file lawsuits this is over the weekend
she was going to file lawsuits in
georgia and it would be quote unquote
biblical this is the language that she's
using i mean these are big words she's
using right kraken
biblical okay at a certain point you're
actually going to have to show the
tsunami of evidence that you have hidden
behind door number three here here was
sydney powell jordan sekulow said that
there's going to be a filing soon in
georgia
that would be explosive can you tell us
anything can you make some news with us
here tonight
tell us anything new that you're going
to present in that filing in georgia
well i'm i
i can't say that yet but hopefully this
week
we will we will get it ready to file
sydney what's in it it will it will be
biblical
then she even went further and she
suggested that in georgia the reason
that trump lost even though there's a
republican secretary of state and a
republican governor
is because essentially the republican
governor brian kemp had been paid off
that he was complicit in the uh in the
dominion scandal she then suggested that
bernie
sanders was also complicit in the
dominion scandal because he had been
jobbed by hillary clinton back in 2016
using dominion voter machines and had
gone along with it for the sake of party
unity here's sidney powell
you're broadening the accusations now
georgia is probably going to be the
first state i'm going to blow up and
and mr kemp and the secretary of state
need to go with it because
they're in on the dominion scam with
their last minute purchase
or award of a contract a dominion of 100
million dollars
the state bureau of investigation for
georgia ought to be looking into the
financial benefits received by mr kemp
and
and the secretary of state's family
about that time
just to clarify you're saying that
governor kemp who's been a longtime ally
of the president
is it is directly involved because of
financial benefit in the conspiracy to
defeat the president in georgia
we have certainly been told that there
is evidence of that
okay i mean the the i have certainly
been told that brian kemp is guilty
of being paid off by dominion in order
to
shift votes or to go along with i mean
these are these are criminal allegations
she's accusing people of criminal
behavior
i hate it when people on the left do
this to people on the right i'm not a
big fan of when people
throw around criminal type accusations
without any sort of supporting evidence
or even a compelling legal theory
right so so this obviously went too far
even for
team trump because over the weekend
sydney powell was fired from team trump
okay so that is a pretty good indicator
that even team trump didn't
believe that she had the goods that she
was referring to in all of this which is
you know bad news for team trump because
obviously team trump needs that sort of
evidence in order to overturn election
results in places like michigan
or pennsylvania or georgia or arizona
again president trump would need to win
arizona and georgia and pennsylvania
or you need to win georgia and
pennsylvania and michigan in order to
win the election
at this point which would require
overturning of those votes via evidence
of significant significant
voter fraud okay we'll get to more of
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that you need
life insurance if you're a responsible
human being you want to make sure
that your family is taking care of in
case god forbid something should happen
to you
shopping for life insurance can seem
really daunting but if you've got loved
ones depending on you it's also really
important which is why policy genius
makes it easy
they combine a cutting-edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time
and save you money right now you could
say 50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance when you're
shopping for a policy that could last
for more than a decade the savings
really do start to add up here's how it
works first
you head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting
at as little as one dollar a day you
might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape
part of that is that they work for you
not the insurance company which is
fantastic if you hit speed bumps they
will take care of everything for you
because again they work for you
that kind of has earned policy genius a
five-star rating across over 1600
reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you need
life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes policy genius when it comes to
insurance it is nice and important
to get it right okay so again sydney
powell had made these accusations she
had made many of them from the podium
with jenna ellis and rudy giuliani
in that blockbuster press conference
last week
well then dominion representatives went
on television they said listen
there's really no evidence of anything
that is being alleged right here we
actually don't have any relationship
with smart tech we haven't had any
relationship with sequoia which owns
smart tech
for quite a while smart tech itself is
not a venezuelan run company it's not
run by the venezuelan government it was
run by a
venezuelan expatriate living in boca
raton florida originally
i say here's dominion saying you know we
keep hearing these allegations that
we've done
a horrible job here but we're still
waiting to see the evidence that we did
a horrible job
i've got the facts on my side and the
president's attorneys will go on to
press conferences
will go on tv and make these crazy
allegations
and then 30 times they've gone to court
and they have not offered a scintilla of
proof
so all i can say until we would love to
see any facts and evidence they have
thus far we have seen none okay so
all of this would have just been a sort
of right-left battle over dominion
voting machines except that
last week on sunday this yesterday rudy
giuliani angela and jenna ellis actually
released a statement firing sydney
powell
so now you either believe that giuliani
and ella's have been paid off or you
believe that powell
didn't have the goods i mean those are
the only two ways to read it is that
powell was making accusations that she
simply couldn't back up
once giuliani and ella say listen we're
done here once team trump says
you know we brought you on you said you
had the evidence you don't have the
evidence
catch you later there are a lot of folks
out there who are still inclined to
believe that sydney powell has that
outstanding you're going to have to
explain
what the interest of team trump would be
in cutting loose the person who is going
to release the kraken on behalf of
trump's legal team i mean there's no
logical explanation for that
unless you believe the conspiracy is so
high that somehow
giuliani and ellis are in on it okay so
here is the statement
that giuliani ellis and giuliani and
ellis put out about powell
giuliani and ella said sydney powell is
practicing law on her own she is not a
member
of trump legal team she is also not a
lawyer for the president in his personal
capacity
two advisors to trump who spoke on the
condition of anonymity to discuss
private conversations said the president
disliked the coverage powell was
receiving from tucker carlson and others
and several allies had reached out to
say she'd gone too far
the advisors also said she'd argue with
giuliani and others in recent days well
one of the reasons for that is because
the accusations that again she has not
brought forth evidence for publicly or
in court
the evidence that she suggested was
going to be brought forth to demonstrate
that this election was not just stolen
but that millions of votes
were either disenfranchised or switched
that evidence not only didn't
materialize
she is now because of all of this
undermining faith in the electoral
process in georgia republicans have two
seats in georgia that are up
two senate seats it's going to decide
the fate of the united states senate
forget the presidential race for a
second
if democrats were to take control of the
senate and if joe biden would be were to
be
selected by the electoral college on
december 14th if that goes forward as
planned
the last thing republicans need is a
democratic run congress with kamala
harris as the tie-breaking vote
if republicans don't pick up those seats
in georgia so what you don't need is
somebody like sydney palette out there
depressing the vote
in georgia according to the washington
post
trump believed that powell was causing
more harm than help
she was too crazy even for the president
the campaign official said
now she did release a statement in
response to all of this
her statement in response was i
understand today's press release i will
continue to represent we the people who
had their votes for trump and other
republicans stolen
by massive fraud through dominion and
smartmatic and will be filing suits soon
the ships will fall where they may we'll
defend the foundations of this great
republic
hashtag kraken on steroids so we've had
things are getting biblical we've had
the crack and now we have kraken on
steroids
at a certain point you got to fulfill
the promise right at a certain point
you're going to have to demonstrate
that you have the goods and team trump
apparently doesn't believe she has the
goods
that's how the tucker carlson is
doubtful it's not that i'm doubtful it's
the team trump
doesn't believe that sydney powell has
the goods otherwise they would have
continued to run with her i mean they're
running with her as late as thursday
of last week okay meanwhile the media
are going nuts over all of this because
the media are suggesting how could
anyone be so credulous
about accusations of voter fraud and
voter irregularity how could anyone
doubt
the veracity of the voting machines how
could you typical republican even
entertain the thought
that possibly the voting machines could
have been hacked some crazy conspiracy
theory
like this now listen i'm not a big
believer in the idea that the voting
machines were hacked
i'm not i'm not a big idea in that i was
not a big believer in that when
democrats were claiming it with diebolt
and i'm not a big believer in it right
now with regard to dominion and smart
tech
because smart tech technology again it's
a different company than dominion uh the
the
chain of evidence here is
extraordinarily thin
uh verging on the non-existent okay with
all of that said
the radical shift from democrats with
regard to you're not allowed to have
votes you're not allowed to have doubts
about voter fraud and voter irregularity
or or
voting machines being being targeted
in hacker breaches the shift to that
from all of these machines are going to
be switched on behalf of donald trump is
radical it is radical over the last
several years
the media have not been shy about this
jackpot sobiak on twitter did an
excellent job over the weekend of
compiling
a huge list of various members of the
media and members of the glitterati
who had been tweeting and talking openly
about how susceptible voting machines
were to hack of course they were talking
about the idea that trump was going to
rig the voting machines on behalf of
republicans and now of course they've
shifted their opinion so back in 2018
the new york times tweeted out an
article september
6 2018 six ways to fight election
hacking
and voter fraud according to an expert a
new report calls for more money and
innovation to combat cyber threats and
cut down
on the risk of voter misconduct or how
about this from the washington post
as georgia rolls out new voting machines
for 2020 worries about election security
persist i mean where did that come from
weird
i was told that that would be you know
kind of crazy and
and nutty pbs did an entire segment just
a couple of years ago
questioning voting devices in georgia
made by dominion this is from pbs
newshour remember these are all
establishment media sources doubting the
veracity of the voting machines
in 2019 georgia bought the devices from
a canadian company called dominion
voting systems
they replaced paperless machines like
these
made by a now defunct company called
debuld election systems
a federal judge forced the state to
scrap the discredited devices
okay so pbs was saying just like a year
ago
that this was a real problem dominion
was a real problem
okay again we have we have tremendous
lists of of people on the left side of
the aisle
demonstrating their worries about this
msnbc did a full segment
on how easy it was to hack dominion
voting machines this again just a couple
of years ago
what's so alarming about being here is
that you see teams literally of hundreds
of hackers in the employee of companies
like ibm
to be a sort of uh think tank a skunk
works you know for
discovering the the latest trends in
hacking well
an election official barely has the
money for a single i.t
consultant much less anybody coming in
to try to imagine
what could go wrong if we went at these
guys so uh for me the the gap here
between the billions being spent on
cyber security across the country by
private actors and the fact that they
had to buy these this equipment on ebay
just to test it out
i think that tells you everything you
need to know okay so again msnbc putting
out their doubts about the voting
machines
okay way back in 2016 gabriel sherman
reporting for new york magazine's
intelligencer
he had an entire piece titled experts
urged clinton campaign to challenge
election results in three swing states
this included the following statement
the group which includes voting rights
attorney john bonifaz and jay alex
helderman the director of the university
of michigan center for computer security
and society believes
they found persuasive evidence that
results in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania may have been manipulated
or hacked
the group is so far not speaking on the
record about their findings and is
focused on lobbying the clinton team in
private so hillary clinton was being
lobbied
by people from university of michigan
suggesting that the votes had been
hacked in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania
so two things can be simultaneously true
one i'm not a big believer that votes
typically get hacked
not in the united states and not where
we actually have a pretty good
department of homeland security cyber
security system
okay but with that said i'm not willing
to listen to the media's take which is
that if you had doubts
and if you were giving sydney powell the
benefit of the doubt
for a second and if you're saying let
the process play out that this means
that you are badly motivated and evil
and terrible and no good and very bad
because democrats were saying the exact
same thing about the same damned voting
machines
literally 32 seconds ago and then all of
a sudden they got what they wanted in
the election it was hey this election
was pure the driven snow magic how that
happens
the entire new york times editorial
board put together
put together a headline saying a great
election against all
odds they say the 2020 election was not
simply free of fraud or whatever cooked
at malfeasance the president is braying
about it this hour
it was from an administrative standpoint
a resounding success in the face of a
raging pandemic and the highest turnout
in more than a century americans enjoyed
one of the most secure most accurate
most well-run elections ever
don't take our word for it listen to the
state and local officials of both
parties and dozens of states who are
tasked with overseeing the process
now amazing how credulous the new york
times is about all this
when just a little while ago they were
doubting the process itself they were
talking about how trump was burning the
voting
trump was was rigging the voting
machines and how trump was burning the
mailboxes and all of this
in other words everything in politics
has basically just come down to pure
partisan nonsense
and what that means that the entire
media which is involved in the pure
partisan nonsense and will not tell you
the truth about any of this
if trump had pulled out the victory
don't worry all of the talk about
dominion and smart tech would have been
on the left all of it
it would have been coming from new york
magazine and gabriel sherman it would
have been coming
from the new york times we've been
coming from pbs we would have heard
nothing but braying the same kind of
brain they're accusing trump of they
would have been
talking about how everything was corrupt
it was a dirty election there was no way
to run a clean election in a time
of pandemic and everything was taken
advantage of
i i don't think for half a second that
democrats
would not be be talking about voter
fraud because they were back in 2016
again even according to gabriel sherman
i mean they're they're wonderful
celebrity friends barbra streisand
tweeted out in october 2018
why are republicans purging hundreds of
thousands of voters in florida and texas
why do we still have voting machines
that can be hacked with no paper trail
why won't the trump administration spend
needed money on election security
remember this was the line leading up to
the election
is that team trump was defunding parts
of the dhs
in order to allow for foreign election
interference on trump's behalf so now
that they think trump lost
this means that you're not even allowed
to ask questions about this sort of
stuff anymore or you're bad
now again my standard along has been
perfectly consistent all the way through
here
and it's the same standard i hold for
every single claim made in politics show
me the money right
show me the evidence don't show me the
possibility that something bad could
happen
show me that something bad happened if
you're talking about changing the
results
in a variety of states this is true in
2016 it is true in 2018 it is true in
but the media don't have any ground to
stand on here because they were pushing
exactly the same quarter
the same sort of speculation about how
the voting system
was going to be completely jacked up
they were pushing that five minutes ago
when they thought that trump was gonna
win
now that they think trump lost all of a
sudden it's like no one's allowed to
talk about this
everybody who talks about this is a
crazy alex jones tin foil hat conspiracy
theorist
pretty amazing how the media worked at
speaking of which the media
what this is about for the media is of
course reestablishment of two narratives
one
their own dominance and to the narrative
they wish to push from the left we'll
get to that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
look around your house right now and
you've done some work in your house and
it really should look better than it
does
is your thing about your window
coverings i know nobody thinks about the
window coverings now you're
now that i told you you're looking at
the window coverings you need to replace
them right they can look a lot better
than they do right now this is why you
need blinds.com they make it simple to
shop top quality
blinds shades and interior shutters from
home with easy online ordering and free
shipping
the experts at blinds.com understand
that window treatments are one of those
household items you don't just think
about but they can make a huge impact on
the look and feel of your home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what is on your
windows you can change the way light
comes into your home
and you can create a totally different
feel go to blinds.com just take a look
at all the options like faux wood blinds
cellular and roller shades even outdoor
shades if you're nervous about trying
them there really is no reason to be
blinds.com has helped millions of
homeowners throughout the process plus
they guarantee the perfect fit whether
you do it yourself or have them measure
and install
everything for you so head on over right
now see how much you can save
at blinds.com blinds can really bring
your house together make it look so much
nicer without spending a fortune
when you check out online don't forget
to tell them you heard about blinds.com
from the ben
shapiro show rules and restrictions may
apply go check them out at blinds.com
right now and again let them know
that we sent you okay so this is
all part and parcel of the media's
generalized attempt to re-establish
their dominance in the narrative
the rule for the media is this they can
say anything they want
they can violate all the rules and then
if you have doubt about those exact same
rules you're the bad guy
so they can violate all the rules they
can say that voting machines were hacked
by dibolt in 2004
they can say that voting machines were
susceptible to hack in 2016 and 2018 but
if you question that in 2020
you're now bad right just the very
question itself means that you're a
crazy person who's a conspiracy theorist
and to throw that theory out there
is completely wild and they can say for
four long years that donald trump
was a was being run by vladimir putin
like kevin costner in no way out
and then it turns out not to manifest at
all and they just move on to the next
narrative which is of course that trump
is a secret white supremacist
and if you say at any point you know i
don't trust your narrative i think that
your narrative is full of it
they say ah well this is because you
don't trust the facts
if you believed in the facts you would
believe us and so
they've decided to do the mainstream
media in order to reestablishment their
time and reestablish their dominance
after having blown a lot of their
credibility over the last four years i
would say virtually all of their
credibility
over the last four years is now what
they want to do is shut down the systems
of dissemination of information so you
cannot get alternative sources
of information so chuck todd who spent
years pushing the
russian election collusion conspiracy
theory that turned out to be completely
bunk
now he's out there saying that the big
problem is that facebook exists because
too many americans are able to access
information that chuck todd doesn't like
on facebook
i buy into the theory that the death of
the local newspaper is
is basically was the beginning of this
that shoved everybody to facebook
and there's just way too many people
that use facebook as their
uh and cable news is their information
um
as their information vehicles and
certainly facebook is certainly not a
trustworthy
platform i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm yet to
have
anybody prove to me that facebook can be
a trustworthy platform for information
okay i'm just wondering you work for
msnbc dude i mean we're talking about
trustworthy platforms for information
you work for msnbc
which has suggested repeatedly that
president trump
manipulated the election result in 2016
alongside the russians
like msnbc is a source of multiple times
over disinformation
what many right-wing sites like daily
wire are but we're supposed to trust
basically this is chuck todd saying i
know you don't trust us anymore and so
what we need is to pressure facebook
into shutting down all avenues to
information other than
msnbc this is the great scam and this is
i've said this many times
this is what's going to last beyond this
election the move to shut down the
spigot of information
to go after the social media platforms
so that they which were created in
opposition
to the dominance of the mainstream media
that
to sh that the next move is to shut down
those platforms on behalf of the
mainstream and
establishment media so you left the new
york times you left msnbc you left cnn
and you went over to facebook to find
alternative sources of information so
now
all of these establishment media players
are going to follow you over to facebook
and then they're going to tell facebook
they need to shut down those alternative
sources of information they're mad about
parlor because parlor's doing the same
thing parlor is not abiding
by the rules of twitter and therefore
they need to be shut down too
right this is the line and it's not just
chuck todd saying this
we got margaret sullivan media columnist
over at the washington post
she has a piece today titled the
disinformation system that trump
unleashed will outlast him
here's what reality-based journalists
must do about it
she says social media platforms
streaming news channels and innumerable
websites will spew lies and conspiracy
theories and will keep weakening
the foundation of reality that america's
democracy needs to function this is
coming from the same
media that tren that treats barack obama
as the arbiter of truth and font head of
wisdom the most honest president he
never had a single scandal tan suit and
all so what if anything she says can the
reality-based press do to counter it i
see three necessities
first be bolder and more direct than
ever and telling it like it is no more
footing or pu
or punch pulling no more of what's been
called a false equivalence giving equal
weight to truth and lies in the name of
fairness
see this is the the idea here that she
is pushing forward
the false equivalence line is something
that members of the left in the media
like to say so what happens in the new
york times will say
some people say russian collusion is
happening some people say russian
collusion is not
well members of the left say is the new
york times should not include that last
sentence they should just treat russian
collusion as a foregone conclusion
because after all one of those things is
quote unquote true and the other is not
right they are on the side of absolute
truth and rightness and their opinion
actually is equivalent to truth
she says i've been encouraged to see
more of this unabashed approach lately
trump wages full assault to overturn
election read the prince edition banner
headline in friday's washington post
the first paragraph described his
orchestrating a far-reaching pressure
campaign
to overturn the will of voters and david
singer of the new york times began his
analysis president trump's attempts to
overturn the 2020 election are
unprecedented in american history
again this is uh all opinion stuff
right that is not factual that is
opinion unprecedented in american
history i mean
there was the election where rutherford
hayes actually lost the election then
ended up as president
of the united states for example but
this is what margaret sullivan wants
more of she wants more left-wing media
and then if you refuse to go along with
the left-wing media narrative then we
should shut down the platforms that
allow you to find other places to
actually get your information
the only hope says this says margaret
sullivan
is to agree with journalism scholar
nikki usher of the university of
illinois
to appeal to passion as well as reason
providing moral clarity along with
truthful content
or as the nyu's jay rosen recently wrote
journalism must reposition itself in the
media ecosystem to seize this moment in
history to take a clear stance
in everything it does as pro-truth
pro-voting anti-racist and aggressively
pro-democracy
in other words the reality-based press
has to unapologize unapologetically
stand for something
otherwise it's just a palette
alternative to the excitement of
burgeoning lies
so the goodness so margaret sullivan
media columnist the washington post
her idea here is that if you want to
undercut false information what you have
to do is promote narratives from the
left alone
and condemn anybody who doesn't believe
those narratives is an idiot
great idea margaret sullivan great idea
that is not going to polarize the
conversation
in any way more and you can see the
media already making this turn
because as they assume that joe biden is
the president-elect
they've started to treat joe biden with
exactly the sort of conciliation that
they treated barack obama barack obama
disdained the media he saw him as
suckers
and he was right they were suckers and
joe biden feels the same way so t
a reporter for example yesterday asked
joe biden about teachers unions and
reopening and said you know the teachers
unions
uh they're really putting a lot of
pressure on places not to reopen the
schools
what's the deal with that considering
the science says that the schools should
be reopened
and biden got a little bit um a little
bit frustrated with having to actually
deal with the question
mr biden the covet task force said it's
safe for
students to be in class are you going to
encourage unions to cooperate more to
bring kids back to classrooms sir
no he ken dismisses him right he just
kind of dismisses him well
you're always asking questions like that
always asking okay so when donald trump
does that it's an attack on the press
by the way that's bo erickson not a
right-wing reporter reporter with cbs
news
brian said why are you the only guy that
always shouts out questions
well i mean first of all that in a in
and of itself is an indicator of where
the press are because if you have
watched a white house press conference
recently
all the press do is scream questions at
members of the white house
press corps that's all they do all they
do is just scream at kaylee mcinning or
scream at my pence when he does impress
her or scream at donald trump that's all
they do
joe biden gets like one tough question
he's like why are you always shouting
questions that wasn't a shout number one
that's a pretty well articulated
question
but this is what joe biden expects and
it's what he is going to get he's going
to get complete
full-on compliance from the media where
supposedly the democracy dies in
darkness grew
okay which brings us to the biden team
he's moving forward
with plans uh to to put together his
team we'll talk about who he is picking
and why it's likely to take off the
intersection left in just one second
first
let us talk about something fantastic
you can do for your family so look out
in your garage you got a bunch of old
film rails you got old vhs tapes you got
a bunch of old pictures and they're
mouldering out there
you need to get those digitized you need
to put those in a format you can
actually access them put them on a thumb
drive or a dvd or the cloud
this is why you need legacy box because
that's what legacy box does
legacy box is a safe and affordable way
to digitally preserve all your home
movies and photos that are currently
trapped on dated formats like vhs
or film you can reclaim all the
priceless footage you haven't been able
to see in years the service is really
really easy i've been using it for my
own parents it's fantastic
you use their kit to safely send the
moments you want preserved their team
digitally
creates an archive and then you receive
your new copies stored on the cloud a
thumb drive or a dvd along with all the
original media
you sent them with their tracking system
you can monitor every step of the
process so you always know your
originals are being taken care of
over the past 10 years legacy box helped
close to 1 million families restore and
protect
their most cherished memories right now
they're offering 60 off which is a
fantastic deal you can never
have everything preserved at once for a
fraction of the regular price
once you have the digital version you're
secure because these are now preserved
for generations
it's the best deal of the year head on
over to legacybox.com take advantage of
this limited time offer
get 60 off the exclusive offer won't
last long order their kit now send it in
whenever you're ready it's a sale to
remember go to legacybox.com
shapiro save 60 wow supplies last
alrighty we have a lot more coming up so
stick around but first thanksgiving is
almost here that means black friday is
almost here too
since last year's black friday deal
we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program we are really pumped about it
next year is going to be just bananas to
name a few things we've added more
exclusive readers past content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
we're currently adding the entire
prageru catalog behind our paywall
your account now comes with custom
badges that you can earn by
participating in current events
if you're an all access member you get
to join all access live that's our
exclusive at daily live streams with me
or one of the other hosts where we talk
directly with you about well
anything i mean i literally will sing
you songs and whistle for you it's
bizarre
you also get two leftist tears tumblers
early access to our daily wire
merchandise
and daily discussions with our writers
and special guests we're also continuing
to add new features
and products like the entire prageru
library that's currently being added to
the website and
content from candice owens she'll be
launching a new show with us early next
year
and believe me i have big big plans for
the next year
more material different material it's
going to be awesome needless to say
we're pretty excited about this year's
deal you don't want to miss it so head
on over to dailywire.com right now and
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile joe biden is
constituting
his team jen sackey who is a white lady
she says that joe biden's team is going
to look like america which
again i'm i'm always confused by this
idea that we have to
proportionally represent every
population in the united states in a
cabinet i'm not sure why that is
supposed to make a difference other than
you are a racist
and you're involved in racial
essentialism the suggestion being that
your skin color or your sex is more
important than your actual qualification
for the job here's john sackey pushing
that anyway
it is unlikely this is a promise that
will be fulfilled at the top levels of
the abiding cabinet given the fact
that he is currently selecting a lot of
white people for those slots
their cabinet and the team will look
like america so that means diversity of
ideology diversity of background
and he wants to have a range of views of
people at the table so
i would encourage people to wait to see
who he announces and nominates in the
weeks to come
of course there'll be some this week
more in the weeks following
but he wants to have a diversity of
voices at the table because he fully
understands that's how he's going to
move an agenda forward okay if by
diversity of voices at the table
she means that uh he wants a bunch of
people who generally have agreed with
his crappy foreign policy for example
uh that's what he's doing he's taking
all the people he staffed up with in the
senate and he's now bringing them back
and basically redoing the obama
administration without some of the more
radical members of the cabinet he's
apparently going to name
tony blinken as secretary of state
honestly this is a relief to me that
it's not susan rice considering that
susan rice is a pathological liar she
lied to the american people about
benghazi she also happens to be
radically anti-israel and conciliatory
with virtually all of the places you
don't want
america to be conciliatory including
iran uh anthony blinken uh he is
he's not great but he's certainly better
than susan rice also he's picking jake
sullivan who could have predicted that
he was gonna be pretty he's gonna bring
him back
the whole team right he's bringing back
one of hillary clinton's oldest aides
as his national security advisor
his incoming white house chief of staff
is ron clayton another biden retread
both sullivan who was 43 and blink and
58 served stints as biden's national
security advisor when he was
vice president uh blinken's foreign
policy
he has suggested he wants to get back
into the iran deal you knew that was
happening because
biden has of course suggested he wants
to get back into the iran deal
uh blinken has suggested that there is a
bipartisan consensus that china needs to
be
contained and that that happens to be
the truth by the way
is that there are a lot of democrats who
are kind of thankful to president trump
for having rejiggered a lot of the
relations
with regard to china uh blinken
apparently is going to focus on trying
to form alliances with other
southeast asian nations against china
that'd be creation of trade deals and
trade blocs in that particular area of
the world the iran policy is a disaster
blinking
did recommend to biden that he supported
the iraq war he also recommended to
the obama team that they put many many
more troops in syria
in the first place in the middle of the
civil war so blinken is
kind of traditional hillary clinton
democratic foreign policy which is
not great but who else would you expect
biden to pick susan rice didn't endorse
the pick which is the worst thing that
has happened to lincoln
all the way through he suggested that
trump had helped
china advance its own key strategic
goals which of course is very silly but
lincoln says biden would quote step up
defenses of
taiwan's democracy by exposing beijing's
efforts to interfere the irony of taiwan
has been a success story over the last
decades in terms of how the u.s and
china
have handled it now that that of course
is ridiculous like exposing china's
efforts to interfere in the taiwanese
democracy
is not going to do much you actually
have to arm the taiwanese to fend off a
chinese
attack the bottom line here is that
if people were hoping for a
transformational woke biden
administration
uh early indicators is that is not the
direction in which biden is moving now
we'll see if the left sits still
for that that is going to be the amusing
part of all of this is watching is the
left it turns on biden as it becomes
clear that he's just a doddering old
career democrat who's willing to blow
with the wind
right that that's going to be the fun
part is that it's going to be receded
like rashida talib tweeted out today
in anti-semitic fashion because lincoln
is apparently jewish she tweeted out
that uh she's fine with lincoln so long
as she doesn't force her to not say mean
things about benjamin netanyahu
so that's a that's going to be fun to
watch the squad go up against
joe biden and the democratic party if
indeed joe biden is picked
by the electoral college on december
14th as currently constituted
so the the conflict inside the
democratic party has just begun
uh one final note here when it comes to
the presidential election
again lynn wood who is filing lawsuits
on behalf of trump and georgia is saying
that republicans shouldn't show up to
the polls to vote in the georgia center
right that's insane that's insane go out
and vote in the georgia
senate race okay meanwhile your update
on covet so uh covet continues to wash
across the land we have record numbers
of hospitalizations
uh last i checked it was like 70 000
people who had been hospitalized we have
record number of icu's about 16
000 people in the icu right now we have
seen
a vast number of diagnosed cases
apparently upwards of three million
people are transmitting the virus
at this time and if you've talked to
people in your own life you know that
there are a lot of people who are
getting it i know
thank god the virus is not an
extraordinarily deadly virus it's not
bubonic plague it is more deadly than
the flu
it is mostly dangerous to people who
have as i've said many times
pre-existing conditions
particularly if you happen to be obese
if you have diabetes
if you've had prior lung conditions
right these are these are all conditions
that are exacerbated
by covid and covet is likely to do more
harm to you than if you are young
and healthy but that does not justify
the media's treatment
of of covet the media have been
attempting to create a political
narrative around covert for quite a
while the political narrative goes
something like this if you're a democrat
you avoid covet if you're not a democrat
then there's no way for you to avoid
covet because you're bad and terrible uh
one story that came out over the weekend
that is indicative of this so you
remember last week
there was this nurse who appeared on cnn
and she claimed that she'd been going
around in the nursing ward and people
were just dying
his body's piled up everywhere and
people were telling her as they were
dying they did not believe that coveted
was deadly
and we played a clip of this it was from
cnn
and this is treated with great shock by
the media oh my god look at this
delusional
these delusional red staters it's just
terrible well turns out
the lady definitely could have been
lying according to national review
a south dakota nurse gained national
attention this week for a tweet claiming
that some of her dying coronavirus
patients refused to admit the virus is
real
jody dearing a traveling nurse who lives
in a small small eastern south dakota
town
had saturday night off of work and was
at home eating ice cream on her couch
when she posted a twitter thread in
which she said she couldn't stop
thinking about covet 19 patients who
quote
still don't believe the virus is real
the ones who scream at you from magic
medicine and that joe biden is going to
ruin the u.s
she wrote that patients gasping for
breath on a respiratory support system
quote tell you there must be another
reason they are sick because they don't
have covet because it's not real
yes this really happens wrote daring who
often tweets about the dangers of the
virus in addition to tweeting her
support for left-wing causes like black
lives matter
she's also a regular twitter critic of
south dakota's republican governor
christie gnome and president trump whom
she has called
very i would say eloquently both a
jackhole and an f-stick
so she she's she's a charmer her tweet
about the coronavirus denial
and the fear of a draebite in presidency
gripping her dying patients has been
retweeted more than 71 000 times
she ended up on cnn's new day she said
her tweet wasn't about one person but
many people a culmination of so many
people
and their last dying words are this
can't be happening it's not real
when they should be spending time
facetiming their families they're filled
with anger
and hatred and then of course the
washington post pushed a story and usa
today
pushed a story neither of those news
organizations bothered to track down who
are the people she was actually talking
about
national review was unable to reach
during on the phone or on twitter for
comment or get a sense of how widespread
she believes
kovid's denialism is among her patients
south dakota of course is a reliably
republican state and more than
three-quarters of the voters in
jericho's county voted for trump
there have been 644 deaths from covet 19
in south dakota currently they have the
nation's highest positivity rate
nome has publicly questioned the
effectiveness of mass in slowing the
virus is spread
and has refused to institute a mask at
mandate but the evidence
of of jiren's tweets being true
is very very very thin kim rieger a
spokeswoman for the huron regional
medical center
one of the hospitals where during work
said after daring's claims went viral
she did an informal poll about half a
dozen other nurses
she said no one else has gotten that
statement back from a patient
specifically nor have they heard of that
happening here
not to call her a liar because she
provides care here as well as other
hospitals
it could have happened in another
hospital she uh she said i read these
tweets and i think she was at her end
it might have been a better conversation
for her girlfriends than twitter nathan
johnson
a spokesman a spokesman for avera health
system which operates several hospitals
in the region
said he hadn't heard of any cases of
cover denial in the system is it based
on one informal conversation i had
a nurse leader said they hadn't heard
anything like that taking place
during noted that not all of her coveted
positive patients deny the existence of
the virus
but she insisted that this is not
political so in other words
no one from any of the hospitals where
this lady works so far has come out and
actually confirmed her story didn't
matter it was too good to check the
entire media decided to run with the
idea
that patients who are dying of covet in
south dakota are basically saying with
their last
dying breath that the virus is a lie
this is all part of this
narrative put forth by democrats and put
forth by the media
that the only people who care about
covet are people who are democrats
which has led to the the investigation
of bizarre policies the instigation of
bizarre policies
in new york city obviously they've now
shut down the school system for no
apparent reason
at all i mean really like they know that
it's a bad idea they know the positivity
rate the new york schooling system was
0.23
they shut it down anyway they said they
had to they did not have to of course
meanwhile in los angeles they shut down
in-person dining even outdoors
according to erica quintinar at daily
wire l.a county public health officials
said sunday afternoon restaurants will
be forced to stop
all in-person dining services due to the
ongoing spread of the coronavirus the
policy will go into effect the day
before thanksgiving and last for at
least
three weeks you can't visit breweries
wineries or bars in the county either
la county public health director barbara
ferrar said in a statement on sunday
as we modify our thanksgiving holiday
celebrations we're reminded of the many
families who will miss their loved ones
we send wishes for healing and peace
the persistent high number of cases
requires additional safety measures that
limit mixing in settings where people
are not wearing masks
businesses are going to go back to
having to rely on takeout delivery and
drive through services
that comes less than a week after
governor gavin newsom unveiled a
stay-at-home order that prohibits
non-essential work and gatherings
in most of the state's counties from 10
pm to 5 a.m for a month and of course he
has called
for a curfew as well nearly 95 percent
of california's
40 million residents live in so-called
purple tier counties which are the
shutdown counties
meanwhile california health and human
services secretary mark galey has warned
the state may quote need to make
more may need to take more stringent
actions if we are unable to flatten the
curve quickly
taking these hard temporary actions now
could help prevent future shutdowns
and they're warning there may be more
restrictions in l.a county as well
i mean very very solid stuff here
seriously
except that gavin newsom has also
decided that non-essential work
that does not include the entertainment
industry so his friends in the
entertainment industry continue to keep
working
deadline hollywood reports that gavin
newsom's office said thursday the order
would not apply to workers in the
entertainment industry
those workers have been deemed essential
the original order included a list of
essential critical infrastructure
workers
to help state local tribal and industry
partners as they work to protect
communities while ensuring continuity of
functions critical to public health and
safety
as well as economic and national
security on the list of exemptions there
is essential works at worker designation
15 it reads workers supporting the
entertainment industries studios and
other related establishments
provided they follow coveted 19 public
health guidance around
physical distancing so in other words
the schools are still closed in l.a
county last time i checked
no schools yes on
the kissing scenes in the movies
uh what now so the entertainment
industry is deemed vital
by gavin newsom but it is not vital that
you'll be able to go to church
very interesting how they've decided
what is essential and what in fact is
non-essential as far as by the way
outdoor dining over the weekend governor
phil murphy of new jersey who's been
one of the the strictest coveted
lockdown advocates
he was spotted dining with his family
outdoors and somebody went up at him and
started screaming first of all bad
policy never scream at people guys like
don't scream at politicians it's rude
and it's nasty but
it's phil murphy a massive hypocrite
absolutely is gavin newsom the biggest
hypocrite in the world he's shutting
down
every restaurant he or la county at
least is shutting down
every restaurant outdoors every
restaurant outdoors in l.a county is now
being shut down for outdoor dining
which is not a leading source of
transmission and indoor dining is one
thing
outdoor dining if you're socially
distance is not really a danger
you're outdoors okay and the idea here
is that gavin newsom can still go to the
french laundry
in order to eat a 400 a plate dinner
with the california medical association
officials
they don't care about the standards this
is all it's nonsense you can take
rational measures to protect yourself
and protect your family
you can do all of that without having to
have these government
dunderheads picking a standard that they
themselves will not abide by this of
course resulted in giant protests in
huntington beach
over the weekend in what local media
described as a massive crowd of
protesters they assembled in huntington
beach california on saturday night
to defy gavin newsom's months-long
curfew order that took effect for most
of the state
at 10 pm the new mandate of plastic
counties in the state's most restrictive
purple tier of the reopening plan in
which about 94 percent
of californians reside demonstrators
lined the sidewalk around the huntington
beach pier at pacific coast highway and
main street many waves american flags as
drivers honk their horns in support
while driving through the area
as well huntington beach has of course
protested before
when gavin newsom to try to shut down
the beaches because it turns out that
shutting down the beaches is stupid now
the the shouts from the media were loud
and clear because of course these are
people who are protesting the shutdown
um if they'd been out there protesting
systemic american racism and police
brutality of course then
the virus would have spared them
presumably
meanwhile you know just to put sort of a
cherry on top of the coved cake here
um andrew cuomo the worst governor in
america he actually won a
an emmy award he was apparently given an
international emmy founders award
for being so great on tv howard kurtz
reporting this for fox news
andrew cuomo's early briefings that's
what this award is about they were very
good he was blunt he was straightforward
he was sometimes witty and he took
responsibility
uh maybe his brother chris cuomo over at
cnn who was
in one of those briefings after he got
covered 19 will be a little jealous
of his brothers heavy in giving the
award the international academy said
that cuomo effectively created
television shows with characters and
plot lines
well maybe but the award implies that he
did a great job
battling covet and there of course the
record is far more complicated than
mixed
okay so i mean this is insane andrew
cuomo
being given an emmy award for his
television performance
i mean it does demonstrate what so many
people think politics is all about which
is not good policy
it's all about how you appear on
television
meanwhile it is a fact that we are
moving forward there is progress here
right there is progress on developments
of these vaccines astrazeneca came out
today
and they announced that their vaccine is
about 90 effective we have now news that
there will be the first vaccinations by
mid december
meanwhile the the chief advisors with
regard to kovid the operation warp speed
chief advisor and he came out and he
said
one of the dangers here is that the
vaccinations have been politicized that
of course happened
because of the democrats who decided
that they were going to come out
basically against the vaccine
as long as it happened under president
trump andrew cuomo captain
amazing governor who wins an emmy he
himself said he is not going to accept
the vaccine produced under trump
until it has been independently verified
by some sort of medical team inside new
york
so here was dr slowly who months have
slowly up
chief of operation ward speed warp speed
i really think it's very unfortunate
that the whole process has been
politicized
and therefore the context has created
conditions whereby
people's perception have been
exacerbated and we are where we are
today
and i think people just need to measure
here is the problem we have the problem
we know
one to two thousand people dying every
day two hundred thousand people infected
every day
and here is the vaccine that can give
you almost an insurance against that
and we know it's safe over a short
period of time and we can predict that
it's going to be safe
over the longer time and we will measure
that so by the way who politicized this
who's the democrats and the media who
went along with the politicization
of the of the vaccinations now again
there is good news on the way
right continue to social distance
continue to wear masks when you're in
close quarters
with other people particularly if those
people are vulnerable
you know isolate if you are if you are
if you come down with symptoms
right all of that continue to do all of
that because there is help on the way i
mean
there is hope in on the horizon dr
slowly says we're going to be back to
normal in may
70 or so of the population being
immunized
would allow for true herd immunity to
take place
that is likely to happen somewhere in
the month of may
or something like that based on our
plans i really hope
and look forward to seeing that the
level of
uh negative perception of the vaccine
decreases and people's acceptance
increase that's going to be
critical to help us most people need to
be immunized before we can go back
to a normal life here is what rational
covered policy would look like at this
point
not mass mandates rational behavior by
individual citizens to minimize the risk
of passing this thing along to people
who are unhealthy
that means if you're going to have
friends over eat outdoors and socially
distance it's not that hard
it can still be fun particularly if
you're in areas of the country where the
weather is fairly decent
you can still eat outdoors eating
outdoors is fine okay have thanksgiving
have it outdoors you don't have to have
the government breaking down your door
to stop you from having thanksgiving
dinner
and you certainly don't need politicians
who are hypocrites like phil murphy or
gavin newsom deciding that what is good
for them
is not good for you right you certainly
don't need that but again be careful the
vaccine is coming this is uh
we're moving in the right direction here
folks but it is
particularly impressive how the media
have decided to politicize this whole
thing
and treat it as the republicans are to
blame for for viral covet spread
one of the examples is the media are
like the the sort of schadenfreude that
so many people were experiencing on the
left
with regard to kelly loffler who is one
of the georgia republican senate
candidates
uh coming down with covid right she was
diagnosed with covet there's ah it's
because she's a republican yeah
democratic congressman
over the weekend was also diagnosed with
it turns out people everywhere are
getting coveted
okay that's not a political thing which
means everybody should act like a
rational human being and we should
please
stop treating this thing as though if
you do some sort of paganistic sacrifice
to the lockdown gods
then magically everything will be healed
that is not the way any of this is going
to work okay we'll be back here later
today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scie event
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen